]
>> Greg: OH, EXCUSE ME!
HAPPY MONDAY, MY MONDAYRIENDS!
I HOPE YOU HAD AOOD WEEKEND!
I D!
BINEWS OVER AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
MAYBTHE FIRST TIME ANYONE HAS
EVER SD THAT.
THEY ANNNCED THEY ARE
LAUNCHINA DISINFORMATION
REPORTINGEAM FEATURING
JOURNALIS WHOSE EXPERTISE
APPARELY IS FAKE NEWS.
THAT MUST'VE BEEBEEN HARD TO
FIND.
EVERY JOURNALIST THESE DAYS AS
AN EXPT ON FAKE NS.
LIKEEEING A FRENCH BULLDOG IS
A EXPERT ON FARTING.
THAT'S ALL THEY DO.
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FLAT
FACES.
GOOD TOEE MPR REALIZING THE
NECESSITY OF POLICING KE NEWS
LIKE A DG ADDICT CHECKING
HIMSEL INTO REHAB ADMITTING YOU
HAVE A PROBLEM.
NPR IS THE FIRST STEP, SO GOOD
FOR YOU.
THE FIRST INVESTIGATIONIA
THEMSELV THIS TWEET FROM N
IT'SELF RHT BEFORE THE 2020
ELECON.
HEREMPR ASKS WHY YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN STORIES FROMHEM ABOUT
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY ON
HUNTER BIDENHICH THE PAPER
BROKE A MONTH OR SO BEFOR THE
2020LECTION.
YOUNOW, THE SRY WAS
FLUSHED ON A TOILET LIKE AN
OUNCE OF CRACK WHEN COPS KICK
HUNTER'SRONT DOOR.
AUGHTER]
DEBATING WHETHERO REREAD THAT.
>> THEYOT IT.
>>reg: IT'SONDAY.
I VE A LOT ON MY MIN.
AH, THEY BURIED THETORY ONLY
TOESURFACE IT LATER WHENHUNTER'Y
TRSPORTED TO THE OL OFFICE
KE A MANNEQUIN TO HIS DOO
FRONT WINDOW.
LIKE JOB TRYING TO COMETE A
HANDSHAKE.
THE WHOLE THING WORKED P
PERFECTLY.
THIS IS NPR'S EXPLANATION FOR
NOT COVERING THE SRY.
WE DON'TANT T WASTE OUR TIME
ON SRIES THA ARE NOT REAY
STORIE
WE DON'T WANT TO WASTE LEADERS S
AND READERS TIME.
AEGMENT ON THE CLLENGES OF
THE HIMAYAS?
JUST MORE EDENCE OF THE WHITE
PATRIARCHY ATORK.
AN URGENT MOMENT WN NEWS IS
VIL, NO ONE EVER YELLED QUICK,
PUT ON NPR!
UNLE IT'S TO PUT A PATIENT TO
EEP FORMERGENCY SURGERY.
HOW THOUGHTFUL OFHEM?
APPARELY MPR WAS DOING PPLE
A FAR BY FILTERING OUT STORI
THAT MHT DISRB THE
BUT THEY WERE NOT FILTING AT
ALL.
THEY WERE BLOCKIN CHEY
PICKING, CENSORI, THEN ACTING
LIKE IT'S A FEDERATED VIEW.IF I,
SISTER!
HE YOU'VE GOT THE BIGGEST MOS
CONSEQUENTL STORIES IN THE
ELECTION SEASON AS THEY RIED
IT LIKE A MOUTHYITCHHIKER IN
THE DESERT.
[LAUGHTER]
WOUL'T SHUT UP.
THEY CALLED SOMETHING FAKE NEWS
WHEN IT'S REAL, AND THEY ASSUMED
ONE WOULD CALL THEMN ITWHICH, Y
WE RIGHT.
BUT TY KNEW THEY HAD TO DO
THEIR PART TO PROTECT OLD SHOW
AS HIS CAMPAIGN WOBBLED IO THE
WHITE HOUSE LIKE A RASCAL
SCOOTER WITH TWOAD WHEELS.
THAT'S NOT A MISTAKE OR
DINFORMATION OR JOEEADING
THE BRAND NAME OFF OF HIS
LEPROMPTER.
IT'S CALLED LNG, AND NPR DID
IT TO INFLUENCEN ELECTION.
I WONDER WHAT HAPPENED BEHI
CLOSED DOORS.>> OKAY, BOS I'VE E
STY PAGES FOR Y.
HUNTER BIDEN WEIING CRACK WITH
A HOOKER.
WH ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN WITH TWO
HOOKER'S AND A D?
WHAT AUT HUNTER BIDEN SMOKING
CRACK WHILE TOUCHING HIMSELF
>> LET'SUST PICK STORIES WITH
STOMACH LE WE ALWAYS
DO, WITH THE CHEESE NGLES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NONARY IIGENOUS PATIO
FURNURE?
>> TRE'S THE STORY.
>>LL GO READ IT OUT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gg: SO THEY STARTED
DINFORMATION BUT THE ONLY
DISINFO THEY WILL FOCU ON IS
STUFF THAT FLOWS IN ONE
DIRECTION AND THAT'S FROM RIGHT
TO LEFT.
IF THEY DIDN'T, WN THEY FIRSTADY
OUT OFHE GATE?
UNLESS YOU ENJOY TURNING BLUE
AND RENDERIN YOUELF ON
DON McGA CAUTIOUS, DON'T
HOLD YOUR BREATH.
WE COUNTEDPR TO FIND OUT IF
THEY WED AND WE GOT NHING BUT
AUTOMATED EMAILNDESPONSE.
I GUESS NPR STANDSOR NO
PROFESSIONAL RESNSE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> CLEVER AUENCE TONIGHT.
>> Greg: YH.
I GET WHY.
NPR'S ATTEM AT FACT-CHECKING
IS NO DIFFERENTS THEY LET MORE
WHOPPERS LE THROUGH BRYCE
ELDERS DIGESTIVE TRACT.
MEANWHILE, THEY WIL CHASE DOWN
MEMEBY PRIVATE CITIZENS OR
DOCS THEM FOR MAKING JOK, OR
WORSE, TELLING THE TTH.
IF AFTER AN EXHAUSTIVE
VESTIGATION, WE FOUND OUT
THERE WAS NO CAT HOLDING ONO A
TREE BRANCH SAYI HANG IN THE
THERE!
WE ALSO UND NO EVIDENCE THATTHE.
MEANWHILE, I'VBEEN DOING MY
OWN INVESTIGATION WITHFACT-CHECD
THAT DR. JL IS A MEDICAL
CTOR AND NOT A SINGL
CORRECTION FROM THE
FACT-CHECKER.
I'MERIOUS.
MEANS I'M GOING TO GO AHE
WITH HAVING HER ROVE MY
GALLBLDER.
IT W NICENOWING YOU FKS.
BUT KEEP WAITING FOR
"THE WASHITON POST" OR ANYBODY
TO CALL ME ON AN END EVEN THOUGH
I MADE IT UP, IT' A LIE THAT
FITS THEIR NARRATIVE.
WHOARES?
MAYBE IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT,
MAYBE THEY'RE CONFUSED BECAUSE
DR. JILL IS ALWAYSEEN WITH THE
SHOVELING ELDERLYAN, A MONTH
AWAY FROM ING TO JOE'S PRESS
EVENTS WEARING SCRUB AND
COVERING THE MKET CARRYING A
DPAN
THANK YOU.
BUT THAT'S E WAY IT GOES.
THE REAL FAKEEWS IS ACTUALLY
NPR'S APPROACH TO FA NEWS.
THE FALSE FRONT TO APPEAR LIKETN
IN FACT THEY ARE CREATING
ANOTHEWALL OF INTERFERENCE
AGAINST REALEWS HITTINGHEIR
VIEWERS.
IT'S ANOTHERSER INTERFACE TO
PRECT THEIR LISTENERS FROM THE
TRUTH.
MUCH OF THE WAY FLEXIRITY
PROTEC ME FROM OVERZEALOUSFANS,
T I KEEP IT CLASSY.
JUST LIKE THE FLIMSYOP BAG
THAT MPR GIVES AWAY, NOBODY IS
BUYING IT.
NO MATTE HOW HONEST AND GENTL
YOUR VOICE AS ARE N REPORTING
IT, WE HR THE BE AS LOUD A
CLEAR.
YO RESPONSE TO FAKE NEWS IS
JUST MORE FAKEEWS.
FACTHECK THAT.
YES, EVE TIME HE SPEAKS, I
EL LIKE I'M ABOUT TO GET
GROUNDED.
THE HOST O "THE FIVE,"
JEANINE PIRRO
AND WHEN HEERFORMS ON CISE
SHIPS, THEY AIM FOR IBERG.
ACTOR, WRITER, COMEDIAN.
SPK OF THE DEVIL, AND SHE'LL
APPEAR.
FOX NE CONTRIBUTOR.
D WHEN HE'S UNDER THEEATHER,
HE JUST STANDS UP
JUDGE, AREOU DOING?
HAPPY MONDAY.HOW IS LIFE
TREATG YOU?
EVERYTHING GOO?
>> I DON LIKE MONYS.
U KNOW WHAT I WAS THINKING
WHEN YOU ARE GOINGO THAT, AS
THERE ALWAYS BN FAKE NEWS OR
HASN'T JUST BEEN WSE?
SPEAK ONE THA WASY QUESTION.THA.
>> IT WAS N.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THE CAN
USE AS A NEW PHEMENON ON WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA OR HASN'TLWAYS
BE AROUND BUT WE'VE NEVER
REALLY NOTICED
I THINK THAT WALTER CRONKITE A
HARRY REASER AND ALL THOSE
FOS PROBABLY PRACTICING THEIR
OWN MEDIA ASSUMPTIONSOO.
WEERE TAUGHT TO BELIE THAT
THEY WERE TRULY OBJECTIVE, BUT
WE DIDN'T KNOW UNTILOX CAME IN
AND SHOWED U HOW LEFT-NG
EVERYBODY IS.
>> WENT DOWN T CURTAIN.
>> Greg: I HAT WHEN PEOPLE DOTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
ESPECIALLY THE SHOWECURTAIN,
AM I RIGHT?
CAN CONTROL YOURSELF.
I DON'T KNOW.
EY DON'T EVEN TRY TO FLOW MY
TRAIN OF THOUGHT TOD.>> THAT INT
WHAT YOU SAID TY WOULD AIM FOR
ICERG.
BEUSE I USED TO REALLY DO,
COMEDYN ALASKAN CISE SHIP
SOMETIMES AM THEEST PART OF
THOSE  THE PEOPLERE SO OLD,
LIKE TRE ARE SO OLD THAT YOU
CAN BE AS OFFENVE AS YOU WT
AS A COMEDIAN AND TY CAN WALK
OUT EN IF THEY WANT TO.
>> Gg: CAN HEAR YOU
>>EAH.
>> Greg: THAT HAVEHE BATTLE
OF THE CAMP.
WH YOU MAKE OF ALL THIS FAKE
NEWS, THIS DISINFORMATION?
YOU GET THE FEELINGHEY'RE ONLY
GOING TO LOO AT ONE SIDE OF E
COIN.
>> I DO GET THAT FEELING AND I
ALSO THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT THAT
THEYERE LIKE WE ARE GOING T
FORM THEOMMITTEE THAT IS GOING
TO FIGE OUT WHICH NEW STORIESARD
I WI LIKE YOU GUYS SHLD HAVE
BE DOI THAT.
>> Gre EXACTLY.
>> IS A NEWS PROGR, YOU SHOUL
HAVE BEEDOING ABOUT TIME.
REMEMBER WHEN THEOVID AND IN
CERTAIN BUSINESSES WEREOING
BECAUSE OF COVID- BECAUSE OF
COVID,E ARE GOING TO WASH THE
SHEETS.
YOU WILL LIKE WHAT, YOU GUYS
WA WATCHING THE SHEETS?
>> Gre START WIPING DOWN THETHIN
WIPING DN.
>> I'MT THE TERRIBLE ARTIC
IT SAID T DIRTIEST PART OF A
HOTEL, IT SAYS THEOORKNOB
ACTUALLY -- DID YOU KNOW AT?
IT AT THE DOOKNOBAS FECAL
MATTER ON IT.>> THAT DON'T.
BECAUSE THEANDLE OF THE DOOR
AND IAS THINKING FEC MATTER?
ARE MANY THINGS YOU HAVE TO BE
CARRYING INRDER TO OPEN THE
DOOR YOU USE YOUR.
SEE O GOOD QUESTN.
HE RAISES A VERY IMPORTANT --
CO TT WAS CORRECT.
THAT WAS CORRECT.
>> 47 GROCERY BAGS IN ONE HAND.O
SHOPNG, I'D TAKE TO GO TO
COSTCO.
THAT WOULD BE SO MUCH N.
>> THE QUESTION YOU DIDN'T AS
JUDGE, B JUDGE BROUG UP, ITDIDNE
NEWS WASN'ABOUT RATINGS.
IT WAS THE BAD NEWS.WE HAD THE .
IT WAS LIK WHY RAINS IS
ELEPHANT AND A G MARRIES AN
ALIEN.
WE HAD THE CRAZYTORIES AND
THOSE PAPERS.
NO ONE EVE TALKS ABOUT HOW THEY
WE RUN OUT OF BUSINESSY CNN
FOR STUFF BECAUSE EY STOLE ALL
THE FUN STORIES AND THE FAKE
STORIES TO GET RINGS AND MAKE
MONEY AND VE CAREERS AND
JOURNALIST WERE PUSHED OUT, OR
PEOPLE IDENTYING A JOURNALIST
BUT RELY WERE JUST OPINIONED
AND ONE-SIDED, THAT II THINK
EN WATER WAS IN, WATER WASN'
GEING SPONSORS AND WATER
SN'T GETTING PAID TOELL ONESIDET
PUSHING AN ECTION AND STUFF,
SO DID CHANGE.
ONCE IT WENT  RATINGS, THE
GAME WAS OVER.
>> Gre I WAS THE ORIGINAL
SOUR CODE FOR BAT BOY.
>> YES, AUALLY, I DID
HAVE A TATTOO OF IT ON THE TOP
YOUR HEAD.
EVEN THAT IS TE.
ONLY Y CAN SEE IT.
>> THERE YOU G
>> Greg:HAT WAS UNNECESSARY.
>> SO HARD, PEOPLE ARE SO MEAN
TO YOU.
>> Gre IT'S TRUE.
I BELIEVE THA WE HAVE TO HAVE
ME RESPONSIBILITY ON THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE THE NEW 24/ WE
HAVE TO FILL ALL THESE BUCKETS.
A LOT OF BUCKETS ARE GOING TO BE
FILLED WITH RULE.
>> YEAH.>> Greg: YEAH.
THATS MY COMMENT.
>> EXCEPT THEY WEREN'TILL IN
WITH RULE, THERE AREILLING
WITH STUFF THAT HAS BEE SOME
REGION EYES BUT REALISM AND
BONG OR NOT THAT BIGF A
DEAL
I THINK THAT THEOST IMPORTANT
THING TO CONSIDEIS PROBABLY
JUST THE MOTIVE IN TERMS OF WHEN
SOMEONE IS SELNG YOUSOMETHING.
DO THEY HAVE A MOTIVE T TELL ME
THIS, WHAT IS IT, WHY?
IN YOU OWN MOTIVE, BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIME, WHEN YOU WAN TO
LIEVE SOMETHING.
GIVEN THAT ARE VER GOOD POINT,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONFIRMATION BIA
>> I SURE AM
BUCKET OF GROWTH?
NORMALLYIT WOULD BE A
DIFFERENTUCKET.
THEYERE AND WHAT THAT MEAN?
OH, IET IT.
YES, SHIFTED AWAY FROMERTAIN
TOPICSO OTHER TOPICS.
>> BUCKET OF RULAR GRUEL.
>> Greg:VERYBODY IS MEAN T
ME
WHAT DID I DO?
>> JUST A BUCKET OF